douglas ya x bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france
emmanuel macron et kamala harris ont
donc salué hier je cite une nouvelle ère
pour les relations franco-américaines la
faire des sous marins est elle
totalement oublié
ah non mais le rapprochement se poursuit
ils sont au bord de cinq jours de visite
un pays très lent un membre d'exactitude
américain et elle va essayer de tourner
la page définitivement
mais non rien n'est oublié un avoue dans
les images que ma croûte souris mais
jeanne yves le drian ne serai pas celui
qui avait annoncé la rupture
diplomatique qui veut tient et la
tension et il semble que maintenant les
américaines faire attention à cette
gaffe vous le lisiez la france très
fâché dans cette affaire des sous marins
une séquence de tension on a le
sentiment très vite éteint est ce qu'au
delà des mots la france elle a les
moyens de se faire respecter face aux
états unis
oui dans nos diplômes ainsi la france
est très forte il joue en euros dans
toutes les instances internationales et
elle était alliée de longue date dans
des dossiers militaires stratégiques
environnementaux il y avait des dix
cross
fondamentale entre les entrées
nationales de la france et de l'europe
et des états unis mais comment ces
images ont montré ce matin à suresnes
alors langue coopération et à leur
métier avec un naturel est un symbole de
cet engagement des états unis vers
l'europe en a deux guerres mondiales et
on à la guerre fois comme preuve que à
la longue tom les valeurs sont protégés
alors il ya cette histoire commune il ya
aussi sur le papier le fait qu emmanuel
macron et joe biden apparemment sont
faits pour s'entendre pourtant on l'a vu
dans les relations franco américaines ne
sont pas si simples que ça depuis
l'arrivée de joe biden comment est-ce
qu'on peut l'expliquer a
fait beaucoup de promesses
le plan domestique et les américaines en
temps des améliorations
économiques sur le corps et le corps
pression internationale est dévalorisé
depuis quatre ans au nord le président
trompe le message est martelé l'amérique
d'abord et brayden
reviennent au pouvoir et il ne mise en
valeur vraiment relations
internationales une réalité c'est il est
là que le puissance de 1000 tonnes le
monde c'est le centre même de le pouvoir
économique des états unis et donc ses
relations diplomatiques
un qui semble parfois superficiel les
langues de bois les prolongements val
pourrait être aussi le base des accords
un peu plus discrète maintenant ni macro
ni heureuse à révéler ce qu'ils ont dit
pendant leur réunion et les possibles
que l'administration byden pas aux
offres quelque chose de très concrètes
parce que à natoye occasions pendant
cinq jours pour y faire en avait par
exemple cet après midi en conférence
géré par mac ont peut-être rspf faire
une geste vers l'administration français
mais plus important la libye là où les
humains qu'elles peuvent jouer un plus
grand rôle peut-être en
condensation pour le leu leu traîtrise
sur le sujet de sous marins les
américaines vont engager un peu les
forces militaires pour soutenir l'effort
de la france et de l'europe tu contrôles
elle m'a dit tu gagnes délaisse alors
sur cette reprise dont vous parliez jean
yves le drian avait le ministre des
affaires étrangères français avait
comparé les méthodes de l'administration
by donne à celle de l'administration
trump donald trump on sait qu'ils
n'avaient pas une haute opinion d'
emmanuel macron souviens de certaines
déclarations comment joe biden me
perçois le chef de l'état français
différemment
fait un geste un peu dans la négligence
de la perspective de la france
finalement cette décision de hockey est
sous marine d'australie était
complètement dans la perspective des
états unis dans la politique ils n'ont
pas compris comment cette contacts
militaires dont la bretagne la normandie
pas profité bien sûr les dryats comme
ancien de prétendre s'occupe toujours de
110 circonscription mais non plus
comment les bases militaires en nouvelle
calédonie comme le forces françaises
dont citic continue à être très
importants pro france de jouer un rôle
mondial et donc c'était un peu de
négligence
avec 37 autres choses si la partie des
américains avec l'administration by day
c'est une case ils essaient maintenant
de faire le rétropédalage alors il ya
une parole des manuels makoun qui a
interpellé lors de son discours mardi
soir puisque la france va prendre la
présidence de l'union européenne il a
dit que dans ce contexte elle devait
face à un choc entre la russie la chine
et les etats unis comment est ce que
vous comprenez ces déclarations a
maintenant depuis une vingtaine d années
petit à petit la chine a monté ses
entrées à reconquérir le taiwan à faire
une zone
exclusive dans le flou
sur la mer
meillonnas la main dessus de la chine et
les états unis qui ont le plus grand
force n'a dans cette région et la russie
qui a aussi une force navale et d
entraide à empêcher la montée trop en
pissant puissance de la chine entre les
deux en fait dans une
zone stratégique de conflit et là on
avait un petit correction des bâtiments
alliés qui essaient de se présenter
comme une force de dissuasion mais ça
suffit pas il faut plus des alliés dans
la navale il faut que la france qu'en
angleterre et que d autres à l'est des
états unis comme le jeu preuves en tant
que pas cité de présenter plusieurs
bâtiments dans le sud pacifique sinon la
chine va passer à la et ça sera sûrement
en guerre qui déclenche en taiwan mais
et en mettant la chine la russie et les
etats unis au même plan parlons de ce
choc qu'est ce que vous comprenez dans
la caisse que vous comprenez ans la
bouche des manuels macro est ce qu'ils
se méfient des états unis finalement
peut-être dans son discours oui mais au
fond quand il considère toutes les
puissances militaires des états unis et
ceux qui ça représente le plaindre
européenne sur le plan de l'antique du
pacifique finalement il comprend bien
que le force le plus puissant du monde
sait les états unis mais leur façon d
exercer le pouvoir c'est un peu boloss
et ils sont comme le grande un stupide
qui a qui
passe cette fois devant tout le reste il
ne regarde pas ses alliés et c'est le
sait le faut' primaire l'un grandes
puissances ces deux oublier qu'il est
arrivé là dans un système anti national
avec des alliés et à mâcon probablement
à raison de se méfier des ergots du
pouvoir peut être un dernier mot il
reste quelques secondes la maison
blanche qui envoyait kamala harris en
france la vice présidente qui était
plutôt discrète 1 depuis le lard au
pouvoir de joe biden avait été mis en
avant lors de sa campagne sa venue en
france qu'est ce que ça signifie elle
pourrait être la prochaine présidente
c'est le but donc c'était un opposant
toujours et nous y rentrer et la sagesse
de nommer comme son vice présidente
louis qui était vice-présidente
comprendre l'importance de ces gestes
diplomatiques
pour leur donner une image d'être un
vrai
dirigeante mondiale mais son efficacité
n'est pas très fort dans les décisions
mais dans l'imagerie en a collectionné
10 ans montrent des images de l avait
des dirigeants internationaux et si jo
by demain devient présidente c'est
automatique et si joe boyd le moment
décidé de céder sa place le plan du
parti démocratique sur camara sur la
candidate parti pour fair continuité du
pouvoir démocratique aux états unis
merci beaucoup nous glaciers 10 pour
votre éclairage led leurs appels ou des
professeurs de droit spécialiste de
sciences politiques américaines